thank you
[Music]
all right this is something that
actually happened a while ago but it
like happened right after last time we
met so we missed it by a little bit but
um development in this is that this
student is being charged
with salt because she pepper sprayed her
teacher when he took her phone away
during class oh wow yeah you gotta be
careful
opposing sides of this um right I agreed
with you and now I'm taking it back
on your phone in class well yeah he
definitely was like what the fuckling
he's gonna like be opposite of whatever
you say don't you get this yeah so the
teacher it's in English class this is in
uh Tennessee and he's like all right
everybody put your phones away uh this
one girl did not want to do that so he
took it away she went outside the room
knocked on the door he opened it and
then she pepper sprayed wow that's fine
and then and then pepper sprayed him
three different times in the hallway
it's all on a video
she's [__] up for sure
we got the same team here okay okay
he took her phone that's her property
he's okay just I like that you're taking
this angle because you never died as a
much easier to wait
you never got any
anything yeah for sure well like what
and I wanted to [__] well you're
[__] their ass [__] squeeze
workout thing
took that away how did you know
my stress ball
or his back actually I've never got
anything to take him away because I
would never not even your [__] back
massager Kane
kind of like a vibrating one of therapy
2008 at a fair gun yeah
I mean it took at least like I don't
know if things have changed but I think
kids are a little more common to me
are the kids these days yeah I think
that I think that's the reason why she's
I mean that's massive entitlement right
does it say how he took the phone away
like did he like slap her and then grab
the phone oh yeah
this is a common theme that we've been
saying I'm sure this happens all across
the world before media and all this [__]
like when uh we were in high school
where kids would like the other game
boys and teachers would take it yeah
yeah and then they'd fight their teacher
I'm sure that happens sure yeah we've
been covering a lot of those stories
where kids just get their [__] taking
them from in class like the the big kid
that got a switch
yeah and she was in critical condition
yeah okay you know what I think I almost
think that there should be a no taking
away their stuff rule if they if the kid
decides all right I'm gonna be on my
phone in class all right then you're
gonna miss out on this lesson and you're
gonna be stupid or whatever you're gonna
be stupid yeah yes because the interns
because you're not always works with it
because think about it if you just let
the kids do whatever they want right
what if it's not an academic game
oh exactly because the thing is they
could be sucky at school but they could
be winning at life you know what if
they're on their phone doing something
okay that's a fair because we're
disagree on coinbase it makes sense it
makes sense to take away their stuff if
they're not focusing but dude honestly
some kids just let them [__] be a
Class Clown whatever do whatever because
if you don't learn that that's on you
you know yeah
good job yeah how about like right now
it's no phone's time and then someone
just goes not for me and then you go can
like if they refuse to give it up rather
than make a whole [__] about it can't
you just go all right welcome to your
first F of the yes yeah they just like
they can just say all right if you're
not focusing in class then you you put
it on yeah
you don't have to take away their phone
right that doesn't make sense
because then they're just gonna be like
man [__] I don't I hate this teacher and
then they make it makes them more
negative just feel better
teacher to get the f right but they know
that it's on them versus you taking away
their stuff and then [__] up the
teacher like that's still on them too
nah dude School teaches people how to
conform and Conformity is yeah the way
we roll well then that student is
teaching other other students to conform
and play games so the next day that the
teacher walks into class it's just the
whole classroom yeah that's true yeah
no that's technically true because the
kids that are like they follow the rules
they're gonna want to learn you know
what I mean not yeah not the whole class
is not going to be yeah well okay those
are the two extremes but there's gonna
be kids that are like on the fence right
and then those are like oh well you know
so-and-so did it I'm gonna do the same
thing no okay so what I think is you
should still have the rule of no phones
but for the kids all those rules like if
you know that it's kind of like risky to
take it away and you get hurt it's like
all right fine why bother with the risk
exactly it depends on the percentage
Yeah if 80 of the class is good all
right we're good you know I think you
gotta Force kids of doing things that
they don't want to do all the time
hey you do how
well you have to put them in an
environment that like they just have
like sometimes
I think kids don't know what's good for
them sometimes you know what I mean so
that the simple fact of them like yeah
yeah you can't be on your phone all the
time jerk like what do you think this is
what if it's a Playboy magazine it
doesn't have a right to take it away oh
yeah well different context because you
can't have both you can't have it both
ways they either can be allowed to take
everything away or they can't be allowed
it can't be like oh this is okay that's
that's not so if a kid brings a Playboy
magazine then you call their parents
but you let them keep the Playboy
magazine and then while you're calling
the parents they're like hey look at
this
you definitely yeah you're supposed to
confiscate it but let's say it's the
situation where you're gonna get your
ass beat then you know what I mean but I
don't think the teachers knew that they
were going to Peppers you know articles
coming out it's like as a teacher if you
know this would you even want to take it
away like that's when the teacher would
be like this is why we need to carry
guns
okay give me give me your phone
and it's true oh my God
that's Wyatt Earp do you think or do you
think it's gonna be the case where I'd
like okay this is what you're signing up
as for like a teacher this is what you
sign up for the risk of being hurt I
mean now it is no it is some teachers
sadly do know where they're teaching
yeah and that kind of sucks but also I I
agree with like if you know it's going
to escalate to an unnecessary level then
some teachers do just call the principal
and they go hey this is getting a hand I
need them out of the class yeah right
I've been completely kicked out of
classes and forbidden from taking that
course right right in my school just
because I mouthed off yeah I don't even
have anything but like this is like I do
go to esto so let's say like the teacher
and your guys's assessment
um they call the principal and you're
like oh yeah that's a good thing but
what more is the principal gonna do any
different than I think the teacher the
principal can permit you to fail that
student on this one what if the prince
will just come and take the phone away I
think the key thing
and then that just eliminates the
distraction
example and if a student doesn't doesn't
buy or threat because you're just the
teacher but if the principal's there to
go yeah actually you are failed from
this class now yeah then that's pretty
they'll take it'll take it more because
this girl still came to school so she
cares a little bit so it is like like if
you're just gonna act that way then
don't go to school at all right right
then you want to go to the continuation
school yeah what I learned is like
um growing up is a few of my friends
actually just dropped out of high school
and then when I got older it's like yeah
you know what school really isn't for
everybody and you don't have to go to
school even though you know you should
or whatever but it wasn't one of those
things though in retrospect you can say
like oh yeah this person like like
Zuckerberg dropped out of like Harvard
was it he dropped out and you're like
see you don't need to go to Harvard but
that's all in retrospect yeah exactly
right and that's like this
look at all the other people that
dropped out
this is not a genius action it's not
like oh Bill Gates pepper Traders
teacher too like no they didn't do any
of that [__] yeah maybe even require a
different kind of schooling you know
like the mutant Academy or something
that's I think that's where it gets
weird because it's like when you think
of take like oh let's kick out all the
bad students and then they just end up
being low quality citizens of their
areas and then they could have been
maybe saved if they stayed in school
like what
yeah yeah yeah yeah
brought that out of her now she's like
[__] for real but that's still gonna
be in her in the scope of her life it's
still going to be a very small event
yeah but the continuation and like her
repeating the same type of actions over
and over again are gonna be you know the
consequences that she has to deal with
right but did she get uh punished for
what so here's the weirdest thing it
says uh Metro Nashville Public School
said the student received some sort of
discipline according into their handbook
I don't know what that means every
article I looked up said that same
statement so that means I don't even
know if they kicked her out they
probably didn't do anything because they
probably they probably slide with like
the teacher should have taken the phone
but I also I'm also questioning how the
teacher took the phone away also yeah
maybe that is policy because the other
thing too is is that at a certain point
in everyone's life we have to learn and
how to adapt to not getting our way 100
right but this is this girl this girl
decided I didn't get my way this is how
I'm gonna react and I think this is okay
and you gotta nip that [__] in the bud
yeah because she left got the pepper
spray and then came back it wasn't like
she had it right here and it was his
life yeah yeah she had time to think and
process what she was gonna do and then
she came back and that if if she's not
correct if they didn't punish her like
properly or proportionally however you
want to say it she's gonna learn that
hey okay I went too far but I can
retaliate I just can't do pepper spray
yeah yeah you know or or she goes
nothing happened I'm gonna keep doing
that [__] dude just what if in her mind
what if in her mind this is like I'm
getting Justice this teacher's always
been messing with me yeah in her mind
it's like I'm doing the right thing what
if that's it's also when you you have to
consider who her peers are yeah and they
might be like oh you're badass like yeah
it might be a compliment on another side
like oh you're rebellious or whatever
like yeah you got a nation of people
that are like
you're in our group now yeah or like
you're our leader that's cred for
someone else's Circle you never know so
there's a lot of things involved yeah
um that's the biggest thing is if you
introduce fountain pens to kids none of
this one
the main the me too is that like it
takes so many different things to create
this person that even thinks of doing
that like yeah it is like she's just a
normal average person that just snapped
like right because my parents
the concept of school right like as
obviously flawed as it is yeah it's
showing that okay for x amount of period
of time I showed up oh I kept coming to
this place this is my body of work over
a period of time and I proved that I
could do this for extended period of
time yeah like that's what these kids
are trying to learn like that's the long
game and it is a long game right and
while you're in it you're like dude [__]
this is a waste of time of course yeah
but when you look back on it you're like
okay it was probably a good idea that
like I learned to do that because once
kids or just like young adults are just
left up to do whatever the whatever they
want and have complete Freedom if you
don't have all these like I guess
safeguards built into how you do
anything you're gonna lose your [__]
mind I think that makes all the
difference is that yeah you can look at
school and go that was [__] but
you're looking at it from the
perspective of having completed it yeah
if you look at it from having failed it
and say it's [__] yeah you're word
is worth a lot less yeah dude like it's
like yeah you still did it but it was
right it was argument is too right what
was she doing on her phone if she's
working on her small business or
something like if she's doing
but if you're just on Tick Tock because
you just want to watch Tick Tock then
okay well it might be reasonable to say
yeah you should have just being defiant
just to say no yeah like right it's like
I think when you said complete it that's
what gets overlooked a lot with like
school and college because like oh you
don't need college okay it could be
argued both ways but the fact that you
completed something yeah whether it took
four years seven years eight years and
it was difficult yeah yeah and that lets
you know when you get a hard task at
work or in life life I've completed
something I can you may not consciously
be aware and think like oh yeah I
completed college I can do this too no
but you just know how to get things done
exactly yeah right a lot of things in
life are [__] you got to get through
it as as someone who's hated college and
I was like this is a waste of time all
the classes that I went to I felt like
were I had such a bad accident why did
you go to school I went to Northridge
and I studied Kinesiology and it was
like in retrospect I'm glad I [__]
did it but during the time I was
complaining about it constantly just
being a [__] brat about it right yeah
the fact that I got an opportunity to go
and the fact that like my sister was
helping me pay for college like you know
I mean it's like things like that yeah
we're but at the time I was like being a
little idiot about it right but looking
back five ten years you're like this has
helped me way more than it's hurt me
exactly yeah sure yeah yeah it's a way
more of a positive effect than a
negative effect by far yeah and all the
stuff during the time I was like what do
I have to do this
down the line it goes I'm glad I did I
mean the development and the
perseverance is you can't really compare
it to a lot of things because it's
something that you genuinely do not see
the good in of course yet you can still
come out on the other side yeah that
means a lot most [__] now when you're an
adult and out of school you'll just stop
doing it yeah you'll just go this
[__] and just not do it anymore but
that that raises your threshold so far
for like what you can deal with this is
why Karate Kid was such a poignant movie
that's a documentary it was but then I
feel like when I say documentary you
guys don't take it seriously